con nuestro primer invitado al día vamos
a hablar de las víctimas de la
esclavitud moderna que ahora aumentaban
10 millones en los últimos cinco años y
son al menos 50 millones según las
nuevas estimaciones de la organización
internacional del trabajo la esclavitud
moderna es definida como formas de
explotación a las que una persona no
puede negarse o abandonar debido a las
amenazas violencia engaño o abuso del
poder del total de las víctimas 28
millones realizan trabajos forzados y 27
millones están en matrimonios a los que
fueron obligadas en la pandemia de ccoo
y 19 tuvo que ver con el agravamiento de
esta situación ya que afectó a los
ingresos en particular de las personas
más vulnerables más pobres los migrantes
en una categoría muy vulnerable al
trabajo forzado saludamos entonces a
philippe vandingenen director del
servicio de principios de derechos y
fundamentales de la organización
internacional del trabajo philip gracias
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de france de cuatro muy buena
mañana de miércoles como se llegó a esta
conclusión en el último informe de dónde
pudieron ustedes basarse para recopilar
y sacar todos estos datos vienen antes
además
muchísimas gracias a nuestras palabras
primer lugar precisa el informe ha sido
realizado por la cuarta vez
y esta vez por estas organizaciones la
20 la versión
internacional de migraciones la óyeme y
la fundación organización no
gubernamental world free como vieron
mencionaste llegamos a esta cifra muy
preocupante a la amante de 50 millones
una pequeña precisión
la separación entre trabajo forzoso y el
matrimonio forzado son de 27.6 millones
como los mencionaste y 22 millones para
el marino forzoso o sea un total de 49
puntos 6 casi 50 millones nosotros
estimamos las cifras globales como una
estimación
lo que hacemos concretamente es hacemos
encuesta en los países con encuestas de
hogares en concretamente 68 países para
descargar recolectar información sobre
las personas mayor de 15 años para ellos
su familia si estaban en algún momento
en una situación durante los últimos
cinco años de trabajo forzoso y eso lo
compilamos
como una muestra un pequeño mundo de 68
muestras de 68 países para representar
el conjunto del mundo y eso nos da la
cifra de casi 28 millones de personas
sentado forzoso y 22 millones en
matrimonio forzado una segunda fuente de
información es gracias a la base de
datos de la uem que
atiende a las víctimas de trata y
y de trabajo forzoso o de exploración
sexual a quien preguntamos de la misma
forma en qué medida han sido en esta
situación y desde cuándo y finalmente en
la última categoría es un poco técnico
es lo que llamamos el trabajo forzoso
impuesto por el estado existe todavía
cerca de 4 millones de personas que
están de alguna forma explotada por el
propio estado y había ahí obviamente los
estados nos joven la información y ya
sabes de encuesta y entonces lo que
hacemos es una lista de los países que
están ante los órganos de control
normativo de la organización con los
cuales estimamos este dato
philip cómo surge esta llamada
esclavitud moderna además porque este
aumento tan significativo la pandemia
sin duda también pues logró que estas
cifras lamentablemente pudiera aumentar
la respuesta como bien lo mencionas hay
casi 10 millones más de personas
esclavitud moderna
2.7 en la categoría de trabajo forzoso
la respuesta fácil se haya de acusar al
hobbit de todos males de nuestra
sociedad la realidad es que es un
conjunto de fenómenos que explican la
mayor la vida y desigualdad que
encontramos entonces la múltiple crisis
que estamos viviendo sanitaria con el
móvil pero también y su reportaje
anterior nos demostraron el incremento
de las crisis vinculadas a la guerra o
al cambio climático el hecho que haya
cada vez más migrantes climático
generarán mayor vulnerabilidad a la
población y eso explica en gran medida
está el momento de vulnerabilidad
el aumento de la cifra ahora hay que ser
también muy claro que en los últimos
cinco años este aumento significativo
también es debido posiblemente a una
falta de atención tanto la comunidad
internacional de los propios estados no
es que hemos cerrado los ojos pero
probablemente hemos tomado menos
importancia en la política pública para
atacar este verdadero problema serio de
la humanidad claro felipe digamos cuáles
pueden ser unos ejemplos claros de
trabajos para ser catalogados como
esclavitud moderna para poner también un
poco en contexto a nuestra audiencia
el trabajo forzoso el trabajo falso que
como decía es dos grandes categorías se
paró en la esclavitud moderna primero el
trabajo forzoso
requiere hay dos variables he hecho de
ser de trabajar sin su voluntad y con
una cierto nivel de amenaza no eso es la
combinación de estos dos criterios por
ejemplo una persona que está en duda que
tiene una deuda importante y el
empleador muchas mientras veces en el
sector informal obliga a la persona bajo
amenaza de no reembolsar una paga del
salario si efectivamente no trabajos
este cualquier condición es el ojo
obviamente la pagan categoría es el
profesor del pago en el matrimonio
forzado donde mayormente las niñas y
mujeres están forzadas a casarse el
trabajo forzoso
lo encontramos y eso es muy importante
de señalarlo en cualquier categoría de
economía en países pobres pero
igualmente y a una manera más importante
en los países ricos un ejemplo concreto
son los migrantes mucho migrante emigran
por cualquier motivo económico o
climático de un país a otro o por alguna
vía en su propio país y se encuentra sin
capacidad de responder o sin poder ser
atendido por las autoridades ya en
riesgo de explotación por parte de los
empleadores inescrupulosos claro
phillips ya ya para finalizar brevemente
se puede disminuir se puede tratar de
erradicar este tipo de esclavitud
moderna como hacer una clave
países lo han
luchado de manera bastante efectiva
conocemos las soluciones por eso es aún
más escandaloso de ver un incremento tan
substantivo en un de trabajos el
estribillo uno de onna
primero yo yo creo que sí sense le
trabaja sobre las políticas laborales y
la aplicación los derechos laborales y
sociales en particular en la economía
informal a américa latina por ejemplo
tiene una tasa de informalidad todavía
muy superior a lo normal y casi 50% el
segundo es obviamente las personas
vulnerables en la economía informal y
formal que no tiene la capacidad de
organizarse y defender sus derechos van
a tener más vulnerabilidad obviamente
frente a estos fenómenos el tercer
elemento que es absolutamente clave es
obviamente aplicar las leyes
concretamente en la práctica no
solamente ponerlo en textos jurídicos
eso significa invertido en inspección
laboral y invertir en la capacidad de la
justicia de dar efectivamente y cumplir
con la ley existente y finalmente esos
dos elementos esenciales es mejorar los
sistemas de protección social que sea
preventivo en caso de enfermedad por
ejemplo una persona tenga acceso a
servicios de salud y no debe ponerse en
el riesgo de
endeudamiento y por lo tanto la
posibilidad de trabajo forzoso pero
también asistencia a víctimas de trata
existe actualmente una falta de
relaciones en sistema que puede recoger
estas personas y finalmente y en muchos
países lo vemos los fenómenos
migratorios se están en aumento
yo creo que es importante que los países
de cmg que receptores de emigrantes
tengan procesos legislaciones y lo
aplican que sea justo equitativo para la
población migrante para proteger
plantando los migrantes que también los
trabajadores nacionales